[Applause]
alec baldwin fired a prop gun on the set
of his film rust on thursday
accidentally shooting and killing the
film cinematographer helena hutchins and
injuring the film's director joel sousa
according to authorities 42 year old
hutchins was transported by helicopter
to university of new mexico hospital in
albuquerque where she was pronounced
dead by medical personnel 48 year old
sousa was receiving emergency medical
care after being transported by
ambulance to christus saint vincent
regional medical center in santa fe on
friday morning actress frances fisher
who co-stars in the film said sousa was
out of the hospital and recovering it's
unclear how the incident occurred or the
circumstances surrounding the
discharging of the prop gun the
sheriff's department tells et quote this
investigation remains open and active no
charges have been filed in regard to
this incident witnesses continue to be
interviewed by detectives
on thursday morning before the tragic
accident baldwin shared this pick from
the set of the western alongside the
caption quote back to in person at the
office blimey it's exhausting
earlier in the week hutchins posted this
clip writing one of the perks of
shooting a western is you get to ride
horses on your day off
she also shared several shots of the
scenery as well as this group shot of
the cast and crew of rust on thursday
following the news of her death joe
manganiello paid tribute to hutchins who
was the director of production on his
film archenemy posting this black and
white photo and writing in part quote
she had such an eye and a visual style
she was the kind of cinematographer that
you wanted to see succeed because you
wanted to see what she could pull off
next and she was a fantastic person she
was a great collaborator and an ally to
anyone in front of her camera everyone
who knew her was rooting for her the 44
year old actor went on expressing his
disbelief quote i can't believe that
this could happen in this day and age
gunfire from a prop gun could kill a
crew member this is a horrible tragedy
while it is uncommon accidental deaths
have been caused by prop guns using
blank cartridges on sets in the past how
do you feel about the show being picked
up well i was delighted of course
actor john eric hexsom died from an
inadvertent self-inflicted head injury
caused by a blank on the set of the tv
show cover-up in 1984.
the crow
is my guide i don't know if there's any
tie-in
to the raven but i do get to quote some
good edgar allan poe lines in this and
brandon lee the son of screen legend
bruce lee died after being shot with an
improperly made blank round during the
filming of the crow in 1993.
actor brandon lee 28
died at 104 pm eastern standard time
wednesday at new hannover regional
medical center
he was brought to the medical center's
emergency department with a penetrating
wound to the abdomen
shortly after 1 am wednesday
on thursday lee's sister shannon lee
tweeted her condolences
quote our hearts go out to the family of
helena hutchins and joel sousa and all
involved in the incident on rust no one
should ever be killed by a gun on a film
set
period
you